no solo
[Música]
y pues este tema de las redes sociales
es algo que me apasiona mucho y creo que
a muchos de ustedes he tenido la fortuna
de conocerlo es precisamente a través de
algunas de las tantas redes sociales que
actualmente existen pues bueno estamos
en la era digital y cada vez son más los
usuarios que se suman al uso de las
tecnologías con el objetivo de
incorporarse a las nuevas dinámicas
impuestas precisamente por las redes
sociales gracias a la penetración de
internet a nivel global y especialmente
en méxico en donde más del 50% de la
población tiene presencia en las
plataformas digitales es importante
decir que debemos crear presencia en las
redes sociales pero de manera positiva
mis proyectos en redes sociales se
iniciaron desde 2007 en youtube cuando
quise compartir alguna experiencia que
tuve precisamente de un viaje y yo
quería que los demás también conocieran
o supieran que se estaba viviendo en en
algún lugar de donde yo había viajado
este vídeo se volvió viral y fue que el
youtube me invitó a ser partner para
pues obviamente participar con ellos y
es ahí en donde empieza como que el
camino de youtube lleva un largo camino
recorrido en torno a este tema las redes
sociales son otra forma de gobierno que
te ayudan a darte a conocer pero ya sea
de forma negativa o de forma positiva
eso es algo que cada uno de nosotros
cada vez que posee algo decide cuándo y
2011 año de primaria les quiero comentar
que una maestra me puso varios apodos
entre ellos merolico me decían perico
otra maestra me puso este tela adhesiva
en la en la boca de esa gruesa pero pues
vamos a decir que nada de eso funcionó
para mantenerme callar ahora yo seguía
hablando después bueno lo único que pasó
atrás se me levantaron un poquito los
bigotes pero nada más
pero también es importante que nosotros
como docentes debido a que yo recuerdo
mucho esta experiencia y es muy
importante que seamos capaces de
identificar cada habilidad que tienen
nuestros alumnos pero también como
alumnos porque todos nosotros en algún
momento hemos sido alumnos de alguien de
manera formal o informal también nos
acerquemos a nuestros maestros y decirle
oye tengo ciertas capacidades o tengo
estas características como me puedes
ayudar a impulsar me y para estar en el
lugar que yo quiero pero saben que
muchas veces no sabemos cuál es el lugar
que queremos ocupar en muchas veces no
sabemos hacia dónde queremos llegar y
eso está bien también es bueno no saber
en dónde estamos parados pero sí es
bueno investigar en algún momento hacia
dónde me dirijo porque eso es uno de los
uno de los objetivos que nos podemos
plantear y entonces cuando ya conocemos
el objetivo que nosotros queremos pues
vamos a ir empezando
las acciones que nos van a llevar a esa
meta que nosotros queremos y bueno
es importante saber escuchar lo que los
demás tienen para decirnos muchas de las
cosas que yo hago
hazme unas casas demasiadas cosas y por
estas cosas las he inspirado en grandes
personas porque precisamente las he
escuchado hablar o porque las he visto
actuar he visto la fuerza que le ponen
la pasión que le ponen a lo que hacen y
yo también he dicho es que yo tengo que
ser como esta persona yo quiero ser como
tal escritora yo quiero hacer como éste
tal maestro no quiero ser como ese
maestro que a mí me gustaría tener
entonces ahí nosotros pues vamos
definiendo qué hacer para poder lograr
esto es importante ser apasionado y creo
que varias y kers lo hemos mencionado no
a hablar de la pasión del amor en lo que
hacemos pero sea lo que sea que hagamos
tenemos que hacerlo con pasión nos tiene
que gustar no es algo que tengamos que
estar obligados
y obviamente eso se va a notar en
nuestras actividades
yo en 1999 inicié la carrera de ciencias
de la comunicación en en boca del río
veracruz y pues en el primer semestre me
di de baja
yo creo que tome una decisión que en su
momento y por muchos años lo considere
como un fracaso para mí era muy difícil
hablar del tema porque yo sentía que
había abandonado pues esa carrera y que
había decepcionado a mi familia no
después entiendes que realmente eso en
su momento no era para mí pero después
descubrí que la carrera docente era lo
que realmente quería hacer el resto de
mi vida en sus diferentes formas desde
la parte académica investigación
incluso también como estudiante y pues
es importante que nunca pierdas las
ganas y el interés por hacer lo que nos
gusta eso es fundamental para vivir
feliz con la carrera o profesión u
oficio que nosotros hagamos así que el
tema de la educación lo fui con
complementando con las redes sociales
con el uso de las redes sociales y eso
queda empoderando vas conociendo gente
que no te imaginas y que a través de las
redes sociales esos vínculos que se
establecen en donde antes decíamos
gijonés que esta persona vive hasta por
decir japón y yo estoy en mexico
ahora resulta que de que esas barreras
se eliminaron porque a través de las
redes sociales puedes hacer esos esas
funciones a su sinergia con gente de
otras culturas y tenemos esa oportunidad
de empoderarnos y de
y también debemos hacer consciente que
nosotros mismos nos vamos poniendo en
los escenarios que nosotros queremos
descubrir también que si no puedes
entrar al medio tienes que crear el
medio yo hace mucho tiempo también hice
un casting en un programa de radio no
quede pero dije no pues si no quedo sin
nadie me abre el espacio pues ya lo
tengo que abrir yo entonces fue que
empecé con diferentes proyectos e
incursionar en el pues decían el youtube
en hacer transmisiones por internet y
pues resulta que eso te va abriendo
otros espacios que a lo mejor se hubiera
quedado en el radio no nos hubiera
podido tener entonces no siempre que nos
rechacen se es malo porque porque
tenemos la oportunidad de abrirnos
puertas nuevas que jamás nos imaginamos
y también ventanas y podemos entrar por
chimenea si podemos un trapo lado pero
donde entra el ratón entonces hay muchas
formas de entrar pero lo importante es
que sigamos buscando nuestros propios
espacios
a veces me hacen muchos comentarios como
de que es que me conoces a mucha gente y
yo pienso en realidad mucha gente me
conoce a mí
y hacer un comentario pretencioso pero
saben lo que realmente significa tener
más 250.000 seguidores entre twitter
facebook youtube instagram ya sumando
todos los que consiguen aquí otros haya
etcétera lo voy a resumir en dos
palabras responsabilidad y compromiso
porque cada cosa que tú publicas tiene
un impacto y debemos estar consciente de
cuáles es el mensaje que nosotros
estamos emitiendo a través de las redes
porque hay mucha gente que se te acerca
y esto es personas que buscan algún tipo
de apoyo que encuentras a su mascota
perdida a gente que te digo que quiere
que le ayude a conseguir sangre que los
contactos con alguna autoridad esté que
quieren que les des publicidad buscan
información y uno tiene que responder en
la medida de nuestras posibilidades
ayudar en lo que se pueda a través de
los medios digitales es lo que te va
dando credibilidad y que seamos
congruentes con nuestras acciones no
debemos olvidar que cuando incursionamos
en las redes sociales estamos a la vista
de cualquier persona es como una vitrina
una vitrina en donde sabemos que todos
nos van a ver por eso es muy importante
cuidar nuestro prestigio digital todas
las personas que en este momento están
están detrás de esta charla pueden
triunfar en las redes sociales en los
diferentes ámbitos en los que se
desenvuelvan algunos ya participan en
mayor o menor medida pero todos pueden
triunfar de la forma en la que ustedes
quieran pero es cuestión de decidirlo y
de tomarla en serio y sobre todo de
dedicarle tiempo porque es falso que
esto de las redes sociales sea gratis no
es pues esto implica mucho trabajo la
planeación implica tener un objetivo
definido y bueno crear toda una marca
con tu nombre implica disciplina y
dedicación ya sea de tu negocio de tu
persona o de tu profesión y después de
compartir que que mi formación siempre
fue apegada al área de humanidades a la
formación académica pero yo después no
tuve una educación financiera hasta hace
tres años que estudió un diplomado pero
realmente esa parte de crear empresa o
de hacer un negocio no la tenía
recientemente ingresé al mundo de las
ventas
por por catálogo porque tuve que ir
aprendiendo a conocer productos
enamorarme de lo que hacía ya
complementarlo con el trabajo que ya
hago con el trabajo docente y en los
tiempos en donde a veces tengo libres y
descubrí que es un mundo maravilloso y
esta nueva faceta le ha apoyado
definitivamente en las redes sociales
encontré una oportunidad y quise
explotarlo porque para mí es un mundo
nuevo es completamente reciente y tuve
que aprender muchísimas cosas pero quise
explotarlo porque definitivamente es
algo que te permite conocer gente y te
permite lograr objetivos que antes ni
siquiera te habías trazado pero salen lo
mejor de todo esto en las charlas
ustedes anteriores que por cierto
tenemos aquí a un participante que puede
explicar de la de la charla anterior
escuché varias frases igual que me
dejaron como muy marcada había un joven
que decía gerardo escudero que hay que
crear experiencias positivas en el
cliente hay que brindarles felicidad y
eso hice compartir lo que a mí me gusta
por ejemplo como lo es el diseño de
interiores
en una casa o en una habitación en donde
te sientas a gusto y más en la pandemia
que tendré pasamos mucho tiempo dentro
de nuestras casas y sentirnos a gusto en
cada rincón en el que estemos un télex
me dio la clave y es importante que
todos nos tomemos un mensaje que nos
sirva para abrirnos nuevas oportunidades
uno de los speakers también hablaba de
que hay que estudiar idiomas y yo hace
15 días me inscribí ya a este para
estudiar francés entonces estos mensajes
que nos va dejando la gente por ejemplo
ese mensaje era de héctor vallejo que
también nos acompaña es bueno es bueno
porque entonces van creando nuevas
expectativas que a lo mejor antes no
teníamos y tomamos en cuenta y eso es
muy bueno line no importa nosotros
quiero darle importa que empecemos
después que todos o sea no es una
carrera contra el mundo también este es
una carrera con nosotros mismos es un
acompañamiento y donde vamos a ir
creciendo en las diferentes áreas que
nosotros queramos pero no importa
cuántos años tengamos siempre vamos a
poder iniciar en la
lo que nos gusta o que en el que
tengamos interés siempre vamos a poder
aprender y sobre todo compartir pero hay
algo súper importante no debemos
escuchar esos mensajes negativos de
gente que nunca ha construido nada
debemos estar atentos a aquellas
personas que nos impulsan a seguir que
nos hacen creer que podemos hacer las
cosas y sobre todo entender el poder de
hacer las cosas lo tenemos ese poder lo
tenemos dentro de nosotros mi mamá por
ejemplo trabajó durante 30 años como
maestra se jubila este y pues mucha
gente ya no hace nada no ella dijo que
quería estudiar la carrera en derecho
presentó su examen en la universidad se
graduó lo ha disfrutado mucho y
actualmente está cursando una maestría
en derecho procesal o algo así y pues mi
nueva tiene 65 años y yo la veo mucho
muy emocionada comprando los materiales
adaptándose a la tecnología esté ahora
con sus plazas en línea primero
presenciales conociendo a compañeros
conviviendo con gente que tiene 20 o 30
ó 40 años menos que ella y haciendo este
equipo y aceptando
bien y la verdad es que para ella la
edad jamás ha sido un impedimento para
hacer las cosas yo creo que ese es el
ejemplo que he seguido y que ojalá todos
podamos seguir me importa si tienen
muchos años hagan y empiecen a lo que
ustedes quieren si quieren o hacer algo
como abrir un canal de youtube abran los
quieren de una cuenta de twitter siguen
ingresando a las redes sociales o
cualquier proyecto
háganlo o sea no pasa nada
ustedes aprenden un nuevo idioma ahora
misma tienda en línea lo que quieran
hacer les puedo decir que ustedes tienen
el poder de hacerlo y ese poder lo
tienen ustedes en sus manos muchas
gracias
[Música]